Welcome back everyone this is going to be my new
marvel moon knight midnight suns video recently
there was another easter egg for the midnight
suns characters that will be crossing over during
marvel phase four with the upcoming series and
movies moon knight kid harrington's black knight
blade werewolf by night supernatural characters
like ghost rider there was also another ghost
rider easter egg during moon knight episode 1 so
we'll explain who the midnight suns are and what
all these easter eggs have been so far and what's
coming up if you're new to the channel i'm doing
videos for all the moon knight episodes we're
doing a disney plus giveaway for memberships
all you have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave all your predictions on the video sure
you're ready for that mr whitman so recently i've
been talking about some of the upcoming crossovers
in the mcu there's a lot of different types of
crossovers that the different projects are teasing
just relative to what each movie or series are
and what kind of character they are even though
this is mostly a midnight suns video there are
projects that we've seen recently that have set
up avengers 5 and the other teams in the mcu like
young avengers but if you include the eternals
post credit scene there have been at least four or
five midnight sun's crossovers that we've either
seen or know about that will be happening soon
blink and you'll miss it a couple have already
happened during the moon knight episodes that
we've seen so far and a couple more will happen
in the future episodes the midnight suns are one
of marvel's darkest anti-hero team-ups whereas
most attention in the mcu has been given to the
next avengers team in avengers 5 which are more or
less straight up heroes a little more above board
i mean nobody's perfect but for instance they have
the hulk on the team he's done a lot of really
bad stuff that's got him in a lot of trouble
but at any given time the people who are on the
midnight suns team typically view their powers
more like curses that each of them have to bear
as opposed to something really cool that they're
happy to have iron man was a good example this on
the avengers he wasn't inevitably going to succumb
to the curse of his arc reactor and fall into
a deep bloodlust trying to kill everyone around
him like he'd actually legit removed all the
shrapnel from his chest by iron man 3. during
avengers infinity war he had put the arc reactor
back on mostly symbolically in case something bad
was going to happen so there was no threat from
shrapnel or any kind of supernatural curse on
him at that point his arc reactors didn't trap
the souls of the people that he killed he's not
going to eventually be forced to drink human blood
from wearing it turning into a full-blown vampire
all the anti-heroes that become part of
midnight's sons powers are tied to occult
sources for the most part the roster changes over
time just like the avengers roster but you have to
start somewhere there has to be a first team so
it all started during the eternal's post credit
scene when kid harrington's dane whitman brought
out the ebony blade from his uncle's castle here
that he's standing in and was getting ready to
accept his destiny as the next black knight in
their family line there's a lot of clues and hints
during the movie but if it wasn't clear his uncle
that cersei spoke of was the previous black
knight the whole reason in the movie that she
wanted him to make up with him before bad things
happened before the emergence happened and the
celestial teammate was going to destroy earth was
because when dane whitman was younger his uncle
had already begun to succumb to the curse of the
blade the more people you kill with it the more
souls it traps and the more you're filled with an
uncontrollable berserker bloodlust eventually you
wind up turning on everyone around you trying to
kill them too so it'd be like dane whitman trying
to kill all the other avengers characters that's
why he's so hesitant to take out the ebony blade
and says i have to try i have to try as it gets
ready to touch it and actually accept its power
and it's why in that post-credits scene it's
mahershala ali's blade character in his first
mcu appearance asking him if he's ready for this
like are you sure you're ready to accept the curse
of this blade the next big easter egg was recently
during the moon knight episodes moonite himself is
also part of this mcu midnight sun's crossover his
powers come from a supernatural god tier source
like khonshu during the episodes his case file
read number 1975 that's a reference to werewolf
by night number 32 moon knight's first appearance
in the comics and they're going to use the moon
knight episodes to set up the next midnight sun's
character werewolf by night aka jack russell
you've probably been seeing a bunch of werewolf by
night easter eggs popping up in the episodes and
during the teasers they've released so far like
there was a promo where he's sitting right next to
werewolf by night number 32 referencing both his
first appearance and the appearance of werewolf
finite himself during the moon knight episodes
werewolf is going to be getting a halloween
special that marvel's making for later this year
so my early theory is that they'll have a moment
at the end of the moon knight episodes like a
post-credits scene or something similar to that
just teasing his character ethan hawke's arthur
harrow character explains that he was the previous
avatar of khonshu but he's not anymore he said
that part of the reason for him breaking his
bargain with khonshu no longer wanting to be
the avatar was because he was trying to tell
steven grant that khonshu was a liar that there
would always be one last mission before he let
his body go trust me when i tell you can't you is
a liar there's always one last thing meaning he
would never let his body go my early theory right
now just based on the way they were teasing that
is that werewolf finite will be the quote-unquote
next mission that khonshu gives him after they
defeat arthur harrow in omit also during moon
knight episode 2 there's another werewolf by
night reference when he's transforming between
mr night and moon knight at the bus during their
fight on the bus you can actually read it says
wbn number zero zero three two another easter egg
for werewolf by night 32 the moon knight crossover
debut where they fought each other then eventually
became allies like in that werewolf by night
story where he debuted initially he had been
sent to kill werewolf by night it sounds like
conscious gonna give him a similar type of mission
like oh there's another mission you need to go
kill the supernatural creature that's a big threat
but then they'll probably become friends and
eventually team up with the other midnight sons
type of characters so there will be more werewolf
by night references during future episodes then
during that actual werewolf by night halloween
special later this year the next midnight sun's
crossover is supposed to be mahershala ali's blade
character actually legit showing up on screen not
just his voice like you'll see his body you'll
see him as blade we don't know exactly what's
going to be happening during that episode other
than them just telling more of werewolf fight
night's actual backstory but it sounds like
in the mcu blade has taken it upon himself to
clean up a lot of the broader supernatural messes
not just vampire related problems during all the
wesley snipes played movies his version mostly
fought different groups of vampires that's why
initially when they teased the black knight blade
crossover everyone was talking about black knight
vampire hunter and mcu dracula dracula is a marvel
character he shows up in all the moon knight memes
too just another connection to all these different
characters teaming up then we're getting ready to
watch doctor strange 2 doctor strange is also a
midnight son's character he's part of a lot of
these supernatural team-ups he helps lead a lot of
them too because he has so many responsibilities
he's even part of the classic version of the
defenders which we saw the netflix defenders
daredevil luke cage jessica jones iron fist the
defenders that i'm talking about are a completely
different type of team though the reason why he's
so tied to the midnight suns is because he has
supernatural powers just like they do and most of
their problems are supernatural related this sort
of his arena of responsibility in the mcu if
it's supernatural related just call dr strange
how did you do that lots of birthday parties we're
getting ready to watch doctor strange 2 i just
did another doctor strange two trailer for the new
one so i'll link that in the description below the
movie is going to be crazy but part of the idea is
that since coming back from the blip and avengers
end game along with the events of spider-man no
way home doctor strange is learning about all
these other greater threats from the multiverse
and his greater responsibility to protect the main
mcu dimension in just reality in general protect
the sanctity of reality also we're going to see
the multiverse illuminati with patrick stewart's
professor x variant in the movie the illuminati
don't all have supernatural powers but just
like the midnight suns they're another example
of a darker type of marvel team-up their team
typically makes the harder choices causing them to
do shadier things in the name of the greater good
like we're trying to protect reality so we might
wind up causing some collateral damage but it's
all in the name of the greater good then there's
that brand new mcu blade movie with mahershala
ali coming next year they haven't completely
revealed all the villains that are going to be
in that movie but based on all the midnight sun's
crossovers they've been teasing recently it looks
like most of those characters will cross over in
the blade movie in some way presumably after that
they'll have more adventures together teaming up
in marvel phase 5 in movies and series however
marvel decides to do that mcu ghostwriter is
just the next major character kevin feige's only
mentioned him briefly in passing the past couple
of years so he's like the biggest question mark
as to how they'd reference him next the real quick
ghost rider easter egg blink and you'll miss it in
moon eyed episode 1 happens when stephen grant is
trying to hide in the elevator from khonshu who's
coming to force him to switch back to mark spector
inside the elevator if you look zoom in enhance
there's a symbol of a flaming ghost rider skull
nicholas cage has said that he doesn't expect
them to bring him back soon but will eventually
see more easter eggs for ghost rider in different
supernatural related projects so post all your
theories in the comments about who should play mcu
ghostwriter and remember before kevin feige took
over all of marvel television a couple years ago
jeff loeb and the tv people were getting ready to
literally roll camera like a couple weeks before
they were rolling camera on a ghost rider series
for hulu as part of a bigger defender's hearts of
darkness type of team-up and they were planning on
featuring gabriel luna's robbie reyes ghost rider
from agents of shield kevin feige canceled that
before they started rolling camera mostly because
he had his own plans for the characters with the
new marvel studios disney plus projects and he
didn't want them spending money on this other
ghost rider project right as that was getting
started talk about king the conqueror easter eggs
too midnight sons like i said are kind of like
the young avengers in the mcu right now they're an
example of another different type of team up that
is not the next avengers like all these different
marvel series are introducing new characters that
we've never seen before and they're supposed to
cross over in the movies and participate in big
team ups but not all of them are just feeding into
avengers 5. some of them will be in avengers
5 but not all of them good example of that is
moon knight oscar isaac has teased that he'll be
crossing over with avengers 5 but also separately
he'll also be doing more supernatural team ups
like midnight suns marvel might wind up calling
it something different but we say midnight
suns because that's basically what it is
so post all your theories in the comments who do
you want this supernatural team to fight in the
mcu in my full moon knight episode 3 video will post
next week just like normal and we're going to
get that thor love and thunder trailer really soon
everyone click here for my brand new thor love and
thunder video and click here for my full moon
knight episode 3 trailer video in easter eggs
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!